I would get these kind of very uh
strange kind of twisting writhing
movements
jazz musician when an unknown illness
suddenly changed his life he was doing
gigs every night you know my career was
was really taking off so suddenly I'm
really disabled and I'm I find myself in
a situation where you know I'm
housebound I was I progressively lost
the use of my limbs so lost the use of
my arms lost the use of my legs and I've
got carers coming in every day you know
to to I need help with washing I
couldn't really prepare food for myself
it took 12 years before Tom was finally
diagnosed with functional neurological
disorder by Dr Mark Edwards it sits
right at the junction between neurology
and Psychiatry so it's a
Neuropsychiatric condition
and one way of thinking about it is that
it's a problem with being able to access
or control your own body normally so you
have a situation where the person's
trying as hard as they can no problem
with their will or motivation but all of
the basic wiring all of the kind of
automatic Machinery of the body is okay
but people can't seem to access it in a
normal way fnd impacts up to a hundred
thousand adults and twenty thousand
young adults in the UK
fnd is the second most common reason for
people seeing a neurologist
there's also a big stigma attached to
fnd from many years ago when people
thought it was all in your head and was
purely a psychological problem it can be
caused by psychological trauma but it's
just as likely to be caused by physical
trauma
successful treatment has meant that Tom
is finally back to playing the piano he
now campaigns to raise awareness of f d
so that other patients can get the help
they need
thank you
Alice Porter Sky News
[Music]